We're asked to simplify 12 plus,
and then in parentheses,
5 minus 1 times 3 to the second
power, or 3 squared,
minus 8 divided by the square
root, or really the principal
root, of 4.
Now, whenever you see something
like this, you
really just want to put
your brain into order
of operations mode.
And just to remind ourselves,
the top priority goes to
parentheses, so I'll just draw
some parentheses there.
Then after that, we
do exponents.
And in exponents, we also
consider square
roots to be an exponent.
So after parentheses, we then
worry about things that look
like a to the b power or things
that look like they
have a radical on them.
You'll learn in the future that
the square root is really
raising something to
the 1/2 power.
That's why it's the same
thing as an exponent.
And then we do multiplication
and division.
And then finally, you do
addition and subtraction.
So let's apply that
to this over here.
So we have one set of
parentheses right there.
You have that parentheses, and
inside you have 5 minus 1, so
we want evaluate that
first of all.
So 5 minus 1 is 4.
So our problem becomes 12--
plus the 5 minus 1 is 4--
times 3 squared minus 8 divided
by the positive square
root of 4, the principal
root of 4.
Now, we got all our parentheses
out of the way.
Do we see any exponents here?
We're at this stage now.
Well, I have this 3 to the
second power, 3 squared, and I
also have the square
root of 4, so let's
evaluate those next.
3 to the second power is 9.
That's the same thing
as 3 times 3.
So let me write that down
just as a review.
3 to the second power is
equal to 3 times 3,
which is equal to 9.
It is NOT equal to 3 times 2.
It's 3 times 3.
So 3 squared is 9, so we'll
put that 9 there.
And the square root of 4, so the
square root of 4, I'll do
it down here.
The square root of 4, what times
itself or what positive
number, or non-negative number,
I should say, times
itself is equal to 4?
Well, it's 2, right?
This is the same thing as the
square root of 2 times 2,
which is equal to 2.
So the principal root of 4 is 2,
and then we have everything
else there.
We have the 12 plus this 4 times
this 9 minus 8 divided
by that 2 right there.
Now, what's next?
Well, we're done with the
parentheses and exponents.
Now we go to the multiplication
and division.
Is that going on anywhere?
Well, sure.
We have this multiplication
right over there, and then we
have this division right
over there, so lets
evaluate those next.
So 4 times 9 is 36 and 8 divided
by 2 is 4, so we are
left with 12 plus 36 minus 8
divided by 2, which is 4.
And now we're finally at this
stage of our order of
operation, so we can just
evaluate left to right.
What is 12 plus 36?
12 plus 36-- I'll do this
right here-- is 48.
So we have 48 minus 4.
When you evaluate that,
48 minus 4 is just 44.
And we're all done!